some people wait for the newest cars to
come out some people wait on lines with
20 people ahead of them just to go buy a
thousand out of his Louboutins no matter
what color it is or what form or shape
well what's the name of it every shoe
has a history behind it my father while
I'm buying all of my sneakers we would
travel to every footlocker I had about
50 or 75 pairs in my room my father was
like you have too many sneakers I'm not
buying you anymore
our visiting on my own so my father said
well you keep on complaining about how
you don't have any money so why don't
you just go up and sell sneakers you can
come in and get money for your sinker
that you don't want anymore that you
don't need it that don't fit this is the
galaxy phone by listening vote for
$2,200 this sneaker was released for the
all-star weekend game
so this nikla is probably the hardest
nigga of that year upon so this is the
bran crown jewel 10 and the shoe goes
for around $1,200 this shoe is a release
basically also the barometer this
championship of being crown the crown
the king he's the king we saw that the
sneakers were silent so fast because the
sneaker mark is so big and in the
traveler state to state to go get 40 to
50 pairs of sneakers other people look
at it like all those are just Dorian's
or those just Nikes they always gonna be
in stores but what they don't know that
we know is that the sneaker may never
come out again